[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça
vous regarde très heureuse de vous
retrouver au sommaire ce soir la
question de l'autonomie corse qui
enflamme la campagne présidentielle
gérald darmanin est arrivé dans l'île de
beauté en disant qu'il était prêt à
aller jusque là après des nuits
d'émeutes et après la gestion très
prudente en prison d' yvan colonna le
gouvernement propose donc aux corses une
perspective de long terme le tout à un
mois de l'élection présidentielle
solutions crédibles ou simple geste
d'apaisement on en parle dans un instant
dans notre grand débat votre grand
témoin lui ce soir est l'un des plus
fins observateurs de la société
française et le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est qu'elle change et vite
surtout depuis la pandémie la guerre en
ukraine là aussi avoir des effets très
concret sur notre quotidien la flambée
des prix nous amènera tel à faire des
choix et même des sacrifices jusque là
impossible pour le plus mal c'est ce que
note jean via est avec nous ce soir
enfin ce sera la page présidentielle à
25 jours du premier tour dans le scan ce
soit le carnet de campagne de stéphane
blakowski bien sûr le regard de
véronique rights août sur le poids des
influenceurs dans la bataille pour
l'elysée et puis pour terminer la
chronique de fanny guinochet sur cette
pluie d'annoncés de président-candidat
sur le pouvoir d'achat voilà ça vous
regarde c'est parti vous savez tout en
lui
[Musique]
on
et
bienvenue à vous chers téléspectateurs
merci d'être au rendez-vous bonsoir jean
viard c'est toujours un plaisir de vous
recevoir sur ce plateau sociologue
directeur de recherches au cnrs éditeur
vous êtes je le disait l'un des
meilleurs connaisseurs du territoire
français sa géographie son histoire est
aussi l'un des plus optimistes parce que
c'est intéressant on le sent bien cet
optimisme quand on vous lit la france
telle que je la connais aux éditions de
l'aube c'est le recueil des chroniques
que vous avez publié dans l'hebdo le 1
et la revue zadig notamment sur les
conséquences de la pandémie sur nos vies
on va en parler tout à l'heure la guerre
en ukraine je le disais va sans doute
accélérer ces mutations déjà à l'oeuvre
on en parle peut être que l'ensemble de
nos modes de consommation vont être
bouleversées vous nous direz ce que vous
en pensez mais on commence bien sûr avec
l'actualité comme chaque soir elle se
joue en corse ce soir avec ce pavé dans
la mare lancé par gérald darmanin vous
avez tous lu j'espère monsieur corse
matin en ouvrant la porte de l'autonomie
le ministre de l'intérieur n'exclut pas
un changement de statut de l'île bonsoir
françois patriat et merci d'être là
sénateurs la république en marche de
côte-d'or et président du groupe macro
nist au sénat bonsoir hervé fabre
aubrespy
bienvenue vous êtes conseiller régional
paca
apparentés rassemblement national et
porte parole de marine le pen qui a
réagi vivement on le verra aujourd'hui
aux annonces de gérald darmanin bonsoir
charles henri filippi
bienvenus vous êtes essayiste auteur de
la corse et le problème français c'était
publié en 2021 aux éditions gallimard
dans la collection le débat et puis avec
nous à distance un corse s'il en est
jean guy talamoni bonsoir et merci
d'être large vous êtes ancien président
de l'assemblée de corse de 2015 à 2021
figure du mouvement indépendantiste je
vous donne la parole dans un instant
mais d'abord de quoi parle-t-on
précisément de quelle autonomie a voulu
parler gérald darmanin et puis surtout
quelles sont les réactions à la fois des
élus corses mais aussi des candidats à
la présidentielle on va faire le point
c'est vous et bien en images avec mark
oman marco pommiers pour commencer
gérald darmanin brise un tabou
aujourd'hui dans une interview au
quotidien corse matin le ministre de
l'intérieur ouvre la porte à l'autonomie
de la corse nous nous sommes prêts à
aller jusqu'à l'autonomie voilà le mot
est dit après la question est de savoir
ce qu'est cette autonomie il faut qu'on
en discute une déclaration inédite dans
l'histoire des relations entre la corse
et l'état déclarations alors que des
violences ont éclaté la semaine dernière
sur l'île de beauté élément déclencheur
la tentative d'assassinât divan colonna
en prison son état est désespéré
l'état français portent une
responsabilité accablante dans ce qui
s'est passé dimanche dernier la colère
est montée d'un cran à bastia la
manifestation en soutien aux militants
indépendantistes a tourné à l'émeute
centre des finances publiques incendié
affrontements violents entre forces de
l'ordre et 200 jeunes manifestants
l'agression divan colonna a ravivé la
colère des nationalistes
il ya une telle un tel comportement de
l'état français vis-à-vis de la corse
que
c'est une expression elle et elle est
peut-être condamnable c'est peut-être
pas ça qu'il faut faire mais bon face à
la flambée des violences
la déclaration de gérald darmanin
peut-elle apaiser les tensions le
ministre de l'intérieur a entamé ce
mercredi une visite de deux jours en
corse mais il a prévenu le retour au
calme est une condition pour entamer le
dialogue sur l'autonomie avec les élus
reste à savoir quelle autonomie mais je
regarde autonomie ça peut aussi une
autonomie à l'intérieur même de la
constitution d'aujourd'hui la polynésie
française a un statut d'autonomie qui
lui permet évidemment d'être totalement
dans la république est d'avoir une
spécificité particulière une autonomie
sur le modèle polynésien avec ce statut
l'état continuerait à exercer ses
compétences dans le domaine régalien
police justice armée en revanche le
conseil exécutif de corse pourrait
décider des règles en matière d'économie
de social et de santé un potentiel
scénario conditionné à la réélection des
manuels macron alors forcément le sujet
s'invite dans la campagne présidentielle
on a un président qui visiblement aux
abois aux abois et qu'ils cèdent à la
violence ça n'est pas sain il faut
ramener l'ordre en corse avant d'entamer
les négociations
ça fait des mois et des mois que nous
défendons l'idée d'une autonomie de
plein droit de plein exercice en corse
ce qui est terrible c'est qu'il faut un
drame comme d'habitude avec ce
quinquennat pour commencer à entrevoir
des solutions dans un récent sondage 53%
des français se déclaraient favorables à
l'autonomie de la corse alors on va
revenir bien sûr sur cette interview est
sûre cette visite de gérald darmanin je
vais commencer par aller vous voir vous
jean guy talamoni un mot sur la méthode
vous entendez les candidats à la
présidentielle qui disent tous au fond
il faut des drames pour qu'on trouve
peut-être une un début de solution
comment vous vous le recevez ce mot
d'autonomie a prononcé par ministre de
l'intérieur juste avant son arrivée dans
l'île
oui bonsoir
à vous et à ce qu'ils nous entendent
en fait je crois que lorsqu'on dit oui
le mot est lâché mais il faut voir se
remet dedans c'est quand même une
démarche un peu curieuse et je crois que
on a dit le mot autonomie donc en
l'occurrence comme on a dit en novembre
s'agissant de la guadeloupe pour
éteindre le feu bon alors si c'est tuer
pour engager un dialogue pourquoi pas
mais enfin à ce stade moi j'ai lu avec
attention l'interview donc corse-matin
de gérald hamo nerfs il n'y a aucun
point de concret de précis donc à ce
stade-là je crois que c'est surtout ce
qui s'est passé ces derniers jours le
drame donc concernant yvan colonna y ce
qui a suivi c'est à dire en fait des
affrontements dans les rues de bastia et
d'ajaccio de corte qui a requis à cons
gouvernement à prendre cette position
quand même une amorce de dialogue vous
me l'accorderez
sur la révision constitutionnelle sur
les prisonniers sur le statut de
résident sur l'autonomie fiscale certes
c'est encore très floues 1 c'est une
forme d'ouverture mais à une condition
et c'est et c'est évidemment celle du
retour au calme vous même jean guy
talamoni est ce que vous appelez
notamment tous ces jeunes qui ont
débordé dans leurs manifestations à
revenir au calme ce soir vous savez les
appels au calme il y en a eu des océans
les jours ils ont eu pour effet d'agacer
les jeunes et les jeunes pour effet en
fait de provoquer des affrontements d'un
niveau encore plus est d'un niveau
encore plus élevé donc moi ce que je
crois c'est qu'il faut par notre action
par l'action des responsables
il faut donner à cette jeunesse et à la
société corse de manière générale à
nouveau confiance dans les débats
institutionnels dans le travail des
institutions pourquoi aujourd'hui des
institutions et les élus sont-ils
disqualifié et discrédité aux yeux de
nombreux corses et notamment des jeunes
simplement parce que depuis que nous
avons été élus en 2015 paix en 2017 à la
majorité absolue dans une liste qui
était officiellement nationaliste corse
il n'y a eu aucun geste de paris pour
discuter de la question politique et il
a fallu vous
je comprends bien mais dit qu'il serait
dur qu'on en arrive là à ces drames et
même 8 pour vous il a raté c'est qu'on
s'est demandé si le président de la
république emmanuel macron
il a manqué son rendez-vous n'y a pas eu
de rendez vous nous l'avons rencontré à
plusieurs reprises nous avons rencontré
ses ministres ses premiers nice mais il
n'y a pas eu le moindre geste sur l'un
des points de notre projet évalue à la
majorité absolue il n'y a pas eu le
moindre geste moindre avancée pendant
des années alors effectivement
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de corses et
singulièrement beaucoup de jeunes corses
qui quoique et qui pense que sincèrement
que le système démocratique sur lequel
nous avons misé ensemble aux élections
et bien que ce n'est pas là que ça n'est
pas la voie il c'est vrai que c'est un
peu se signale qu'à donner paris pendant
des années d'où l'accumulation une
colère très forte au sein de la société
corse et de la jeunesse en particulier
est évidemment le drame d'yvan colonna
fait que a servi de je dirais en quelque
sorte de mis le feu aux poudres et enfin
pour finir
on va on va revenir en plateau parce que
c'est important que vous réagissiez au
fond on a l'impression françois patriat
tout de même que sans cette colère sans
ces violences sans cette tentative
d'assassinât parce que les mots voilà il
faut prononcer des choses malgré tout ça
s'est passé dans une prison sur yvan
kodak et meurtriers du préfet rien mais
c'est une tentative d'assassinât sans ça
au fond pas de pas de proposition
d'autonomie de toute l'opposition vous
dit que vous céder à la violence ce soir
alors d'abord je voudrais quand même si
on y faire un certain nombre de points
le mode crime d'état vu entendu de la
bouche d'un responsable du corse ça me
supporte totalement qui est une
défaillance en prison je l'entends là
vous revenez actions des parents dans
lesquels parce qu' il vaut colère dans
la prison d'arras ponsable de la qualité
du gouvernant tonnes 10
l'appel au calme ça sert à rien moi je
pense quand on est responsable politique
on est quand même capable et d'une
assemblée tels que la corse la paix les
gens comme est d'ailleurs la démarche de
gérald darmanin envoyée par le président
la république c'est une démarche
d'ouverture et de dialogue pour avancer
c'est le président de la traversée des
crottes et crise pendant cinq ans on a
tous vu un vous connaissez les crises
conditionnelle qui connaît
la méthode est la bonne en ce sens je
dis je viens j'ouvre dialogue rien ne
sera définitif avant les élections il
s'agit pas de faire un cadeau électoral
de travailler avec le labour nathan n'a
pas non parce que les maquereaux sais
pas mais ça non parce que les mules les
mesures qui seront proposées seront
proposées elles seront en débat pendant
la campagne et ça fera partie des des
propositions du très clair sur lesquels
les français devront se prononcer et je
reviens à cet effet d'ailleurs sur un
procès qui est fait à y compris celui
qu'a fait le président du sénat ce que
je souhaite moi c'est que aujourd'hui
d'abord le prix d'un la république
contrairement à ce qu'on dit si lui qui
ouvre le débat et qui impose les sujets
on l'a vu avec la retraite il faut que
les grands sujets de société y compris
celui de la corse fasse partie de la
campagne électorale pour que les danses
etc ribéry qui accroche pour vider mes
messages vers quoi ils vont voter il
faut que les propositions que fait le
chef de l'état y compris sur la corse
demain après de longues discussions qui
sont qui clôt aujourd'hui cinquantaine
et discussions qui ont été pour partie
punitive mais que ce que j'entends sur
la corse la course n'a pas été oubliée
qui eux onze mesures fiscales depuis de
prix depuis le quinquennat de macron il
ya eu des mesures qui ont été prises et
je crois va y revenir meilleur de la
source n'a pas été donnée par beaucoup
de difficultés dans le dialogue on l'a
vu lors de la dernière venant voir le
président et les élus année mais qu un
dialogue et des solutions qui doit être
tranché par d'élections alors on ouvre
un dialogue à 23h59 car si j'ose dire on
est à moins de 30 jours c'est la toute
fin du quinquennat et vabres quoi qu'est
ce qu'on fait au breite spi marine le
pen parle de marchandage indigne le
clientélisme et cynique c'est vraiment
qu d'électoralisme françois patriat
rappelle qu'il ya quand même eu des
choses sur la table il y avait une
révision constitutionnelle qui n'a pas
pu être fait on connaît les raisons mais
il ya une discussion oui mais enfin en
2018 justement le président de la
république s'est exprimé en disant qu'il
n'y aurait pas d'autonomie alors
qu'est-ce qui a fait que ça allait
changer et françois patriat pourrait
nous dire si oui ou non il y a eu des
tentatives de négociation de discussions
avant le rib l'événement que vous avez
rappelé alors là vous faites référence à
un article du canard enchaîné oui
il faudra tout de même dire si oui ou
non il y a eu des tentatives et si
effectivement
gérald darmanin qui s'exprime quand on
porte parole du candidat il s'exprime en
tant que porte parole du président de la
république et demande du gouvernement
c'est scandaleux on est à un mois d'une
élection où son mandat est en jeu il n'a
évidemment pas les pouvoirs de mettre en
oeuvre ce qu'il dit et on ne sait déjà
fait le coup pour la crise sanitaire
pour la guerre avec l'ukraine aussi on
nous fait le coup c'est à dire qu'on
utilise les événements à des fins
électorales alors nous paraîtrait essayé
d'expliquer charles henri filippi vous
l'avez vu ce papier du canard enchaîné
qui explique au fond que l'autonomie et
le rapprochement des prisonniers étaient
deal et si l'on peut dire avec gilles
simeoni le leader nationaliste président
du conseil exécutif en cas de réélection
d emmanuel macron
évidemment tout ça c'était avant
l'agression divan colonnes vous êtes
d'accord alors on va demander d'ailleurs
parce que c'était à condition que
l'indépendantiste talamoni qui nous l
écoute soit écarté du pouvoir je précise
c'est ce que dit le sait ce que dit le
canard enchaîné mais est ce que ça vous
surprend déjà cette proposition du
ministre de l'intérieur à la toute fin
d'un quinquennat comme ça non ça me
surprend pas parce que compte tenu de la
situation qui a été posée par
tentative d'assassinât de colonna il
fallait une réponse immédiate je trouve
que cette réponse elle est la bonne mais
mais malheureusement elle traduit comme
le disait jean guy talamoni un
quinquennat manquait quand il a manqué
moi j'ai relu hier les deux les deux
discours du président de la république
en février
2018 en corse et l'attitude qu'il a eu
vis-à-vis d'un certain nombre d'élus il
a été très dur il a été formidablement
verticale d'ailleurs sa verticalité ne
s'est pas appliqué uniquement à la corse
n'est ce pas bon donc il ya eu un
problème et nous avons ressenti corse
moi je ne suis pas nationaliste je suis
simeoni smla vous mais je ne suis pas
nationaliste que j'ai été élevé au
biberon et jack l'autonomiste c'est bien
non pas du tout numérique blicain qui
essaye de voir quelle est la diversité
de ce pays est dans une république qui
est maintenant plus fragmenté en
quelques centres comment on fait pour
unir les peuples de france dans la
république c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
cherche à faire si on arrive et qu'on
veut imposer des choses sans prendre en
compte les identités le fait
démocratique on s'expose aux pires
avanies et malheureusement la sphère
colonna elle est absolument
détestable c'est de cette tentative
d'assassinât mais elle est la dernière
femme mais je voudrais rappeler les
choses il ya deux semaines qui abonnez
vous je voudrais comprendre il ajoute m
pour défendre m ouvrir la vidéo ce sont
les corses quand eux erignac long le
préfet erignac a été assassiné
40000 corse sont descendus dans la rue
ce qui est un taux de manifestation qui
est deux fois supérieur au taux de
manifestations après les affaires de
charlie quand il ya eu les violences
l'autre jour il ya des jeunes qui ont
dit on va aller couper l'olivier
d'eyrignac qui avaient été plantés au sa
mémoire absolument l'arbre aux corses
plus âgés qui sont arrivés on a les
images avons entre elle ne fera pas ça
ils ont dit on comprend on ne peut pas
faire ça donc si vous voulez ça monte
quand même que et je vous donne aux
statistiques
60% les français sont contre
l'indépendance de la corse mais 70% les
corses son contrôle du ballon donc si
vous voulez il faut il faut comprendre
il faut essayer ces enregistrements
nationale comme je reviendrai ici la
question corse on va essayer de
comprendre parce qu'elles sont très
frappante quand même ces images de de
violence on n'a pas d'excusés il faut
essayer de les comprendre palais de
justice d'ajaccio pris pour cible un
engin de chantier qui pénètre une banque
la jeunesse de corse qui c'est mon site
montrer aussi très violente à bastia
avec des bombes agricoles des cocktails
molotov des débordements dans les
manifestations vous avez parlé de cette
place claude erignac qui a failli être
saccagée mais ça n'a pas été le cas sans
l'excuser est ce qu'elles étaient au
fond inévitable après ce qui s'est passé
à hal dans la prison d'evin moi je suis
marseillais dont je regarde la corse d'à
côté si vous voulez je fais partie des
53 % de français qui sont favorables
tout demi depuis très longtemps je suis
même l'éditeur de pozzuoli qui le
fondateur du flnc donc je vous laisse la
corse ballon très intéressé par ce que
il faut dire une chose toutes les autres
îles de méditerranée ont un statut
d'autonomie non mais se prend d'autres
donc ils se pensent la sicile si vous
voulez ce qu'il entraîne tarbes est en
train de naître là c'est une génération
colonna c'est à dire qu'au fond c'est ce
drame c'est parce que colonna il s'est à
la fois l'assassin ce que personne ne
conteste enfin peut-être lui mets épicés
en maintenant un symbole de l'opposition
à l'état central je dirais que de
questions évidemment défendre l'assassin
mais le symbole faut l'écouter et ce
symbole c'est une volonté de
différenciation de la corse vis-à-vis de
l'état français et s'ils voulaient je
pense que le monde a changé jeu il faut
se rappeler que la pensée été conquise
je rappelais plus de morts geste avion
parce que chez nous
il ya plusieurs histoires avant avant la
nationale j'ai appris à l'école qu'on
avait acheté la corse ce qui n'est pas
faux mais sauf qu'avant on avait fait
intervenir trois fois l'armée française
avant l'achat la gêne et on la refait
intervenir après le total c'est plus de
morts que la conquête de l'algérie
c'était très violent xviiie siècle 18 il
ya en milieu là la folie qui fait sa
république l'équilibré public est la
première et notamment c'est la première
fois qu'on a le droit de vote aux femmes
sur la planète ils en sont très fiers
les corses alors je peux en faire des
enfants de choeur mais si vous voulez
tout ça c'est exister après
effectivement ils sont souvent devenus
fonctionnaires aux douaniers etc on leur
a donné du boulot par la république et
puis à vivre et travailler au pays qui
arrivent dans les années 60 mouvement
plus que moi j'habite à la campagne
comme un mouvement d'un jeune
régionaliste un peu qu'elle trouve en
corse et ailleurs
colonna d un exemple berger son père
était député s'est pas tu sois berger de
père en fils mais que c'est ça c'est un
destin de ce retour à la terre et le
mouvement des gens venaient de la gauche
c'est à dire que le fondateur du flnc
jolie aussi venait de la gauche c il se
trouve que la corse n'a pas ouvert à ces
gens de gauche en bretagne ces jeunes
autonomistes ont été intégrés qui est
appelée à la politique l'occitanie et
donc au fond c'est devenu une partie de
la gauche hélas non et donc petit à
petit ça attendu les choses les qualités
il faudra comme ça ça c'est la politique
en interne si oui mais au fond qu'est ce
qu'ils demandent ils demandent le
faisais du respect c'est à dire c'est la
question du peuple corse alors en même
temps quand on va leur dire est qu'ils
font couches du peuple aucun jeu pas
faire de raciste primitif mais il
s'appelle touche paris alors ça veut
bien dire quelque chose moi en bretagne
j'ai une maison en bretagne gens voient
pas de vraies un moment le nom je suis
kaka tural mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que il est tellement évident
peuple pense comme ça veut pas dire que
tous les gens qu'il encore s'y
reconnaître les pas question de chasser
ceux qui sont pas nés en force et nous
on n'est pas en train de parler d' et
ni'lin et la deuxième chose c'est leur
désir d'autonomie alors c'est vrai qu'on
leur a donné plus de pouvoir moi je
pense un peu quand même que ces cinq
dernières années ce ne serait pas
impossible que les discussions dont par
le canard personnellement je dois croire
qu'elles sont réels je vais vous dire
avoir demandé à jean guy talamoni une
bonne chose jeudi il est bien normal que
l'état de la république et discuter avec
l'accord pour essayer d'avancer je vois
pas en quoi ça serait un délit je pense
qu'on montre ainsi une bonne idée je
crois qu'il faut se dire comme telle
langue et à la monnaie vous êtes à
distance c'est évidemment moins facile
mais évidemment vous l'avez lu ce papier
du canard enchaîné des tractations
étaient en cours avant le drame de la
prison d'armes contre contre yvan
colonna et qui vous concerne et
manifestement le président à lire ce
papier bien évidemment ne veut plus que
vous soyez influent il voulait se
séparer de la money pour garder les
autonomistes de simeoni en échange voilà
deux jours d'élections qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce fichier ça existe
à écouter là il faudrait demander à
jezzine et donc qu'ils répondent à votre
à votre question parce que moi par
définition je n'étais pas dans ces
tractations et mais lui parie qu'il
était question de mois ce que je sais
pas ce que ça nous avons quand même leur
enseignement c'est que ça fait quand
même quelques années que paris demandait
un gilles simeoni ne se séparait de
corsica libera c'est à dire
l'information dont je fais partie parce
que les mechtas jeunes indépendantistes
et bien sûr n'était pas fréquentable
comme les gentils autonomistes okapi
vous donne
certes tout à fait attendu une semaine
n'est pas autiste et et nous avons érigé
à cet égard oui nous avons toujours dit
et répété que la dépendance
n'interviendrait pas tant qu'une
majorité de course ne serait pas
favorable à l'indépendance mais je
reconnais moi je sais qu'à distance est
difficile mais vous êtes prêt à renoncer
à leur dépendance en échange de
l'autonomie oui ou non non nous
maintenons pour nous le tout mis dedans
ça c'est clair
pour nous l'autonomie et une haie et
encore une fois cette aide est ensuite
permettra de continuer les débats et si
demain il ya une majorité de corses qui
veulent l'indépendance mais saint gilles
simeoni n'a pas dit autre chose bien
entendu je saigne a toujours dit que
c'est que lui n'était pas favorable à
l'indépendance mais que si demain il y
avait une majorité de corses dépendance
et bien que ce serait tout à fait normal
que l'accord soit indépendante et ça je
crois que c'est la démocratie la plus je
dirais élémentaire nous nous avons dit
et nous répétons que nous ne chercherons
pas imposer de l'indépendance à une
majorité de corses qui ne voudrait pas
ça a été notre discours constant depuis
des décennies en revanche nous
continuons à essayer de convaincre des
cours seront je vous fais simplement
observer que ya seulement quelques
années en catalogne il n'y avait pas de
majorité des dentistes c'était une
faible une faible minorités et
avec un certain nombre d'erreurs
notamment de madrid le nombre
d'indépendants autistes et bien s'est
accrue considérablement
le temps quelques amis même ceni c'est
vous dire que j'en suis bien sûr la
proposition qui existent sur la table
chalon mais felipe quelles pourraient
être les contours de cette autonomie aux
souvient du voyage des manuels macron
certes ça s'était pas très bien passé
avec les élus il ya que des drapeaux
français sur la scène aucun drapeau
corse il y avait vraiment voilà des
jeunes est annulé il avait fait un très
grand discours pour pour la veuve
erignac sur cette place et reignac et
cetera mais il y avait quand même la
proposition d'une révision
constitutionnelle qui n'a pas pu être
fait est ce que vous vous dites ce soir
ce qui est proposé c'est complètement
nouveaux ou c'était déjà en germe dans
les discussions vous avez dit au début
de cette émission l'autonomie c'est un
pavé dans la mare c'est plutôt un pétard
mouillé je dirai pas ce que l'autonomie
de ce premier statut particulier à 40
ans les statuts on en a eu beaucoup
la discussion institutionnelle est
toujours bienvenu le jeu qui est
vraiment nécessaire le jeune et fiscales
font ce qui est vraiment ce qui est
vraiment désolant d'accord c'est d'abord
la confiance et de dialogue si on peut
si l'autonomie c'est plus d'isolement
pour la corse par rapport à ce qu'on a
connu dans son rapport à l'état c'est
dramatique
donc première chose que le président
s'il est réélu instaure une relation de
vraie confiance ce qui est tout à fait
possible est ce que je souhaite vivement
avec gilles simeoni et l'exécutif de
corse deuxièmement mon opinion sur
l'autonomie c'est qu'il y a il faut la
prendre par les grands dossiers corses
donc si d'éducation et de l'état de
droit vous avais dossier les dossiers de
la transition écologique de dossiers
fonciers les dossiers agricoles vous il
faut prendre ces deux je suis
entièrement d'accord avec tout ce que
monsieur vient a dit joly à cette
occasion il faut prendre chacun des
dossiers et voir les réformes qui
doivent être faites et donner aux corses
des pouvoirs raison des dossiers qu'on
veut traiter le haussier c'est
extrêmement important parce que moi je
considère que la richesse de la corse et
son foncier les jeunes le
canton et n'est encore établi si le
foncier privé en concert la rente
foncière est donnée aux ou si je peux me
permettre de lire insiste un peu sociale
est ce que je dis elle est donnée au
privé à pêcher
et donc moi je pense que si on a une
bonne gouvernance la rente foncière
peut-être beaucoup mieux utilisé au
service du développement du
développement touristique du
développement social au service des
corses et donc à la république hervé
fabre aubrespy une bonne gouvernance la
question du foncier au fond aussi la
volonté d'un peu de régionalisme je me
souviens aussi marine le pen à la télé
en corse et même parfois il y avait
l'hymne corse à la fin de ses meetings
c'est arrivé notamment pour sa
précédente campagne ça c'est impossible
c'est pas négociable pour le front des
brasseurs en provence qu'on chante aussi
la coupo santo un peu plus d'autonomie
notamment sur une vision je suis ce que
je veux dire là dessus c'est que
premièrement il ya eu quatre statues
depuis 1982 est le plus récent n'est pas
complètement appliqué il a valable
depuis le 1er janvier 2018 toutes les
compétences ne sont pas exercées donc il
faut quand même tirer un bilan de ce
statut d'ivoire ce qu'il convient ou non
de modifier deuxièmement nous sommes
fondamentalement pour l'unité
territoriale l'unité de la république et
ça on ne doit pas y porter atteinte on
n'est pas dans le système de la sicile
ou dans le système des îles canaries ou
des baléares exemple pouvoir
réglementaire
c'est déjà le cas la loi permet pas ne
permet pas d'intervenir quand à mr aller
de la polynésie la polynésie mais il ya
un article de la constitution de
révision constitutionnelle est allé vers
l'exigent des préalables et donc je
reproche à gérald darmanin d'avoir ou
non de l'état aujourd'hui fait un tel
pavé dans la mare bois pour le autrement
mais c'est un scandale au point de vue
delà du fonctionnement de la démocratie
alors c'est ma dernière action faut les
deux tiers des parlementaires députés et
sénateurs pour réviser la constitution
dont je trouvais les trois cinquièmes ça
veut dire que au fond le ministre a
parlé trop vite non non la majorité
aujourd'hui elle n'existe pas sur ces
prenons les choses telles qu'elles sont
proposées d'abord la continuité
territoriale ne peut pas être mise en
cause de même que moi je n'aime pas
entendre parler des peuples vous parlez
des peuples moi je n'aime pas entendre
parler le peuple corse est pas une
reconnaissance de ma tension et la mède
année on sait qu'il n'ya pas de stop il
ya un peuple français bon ensuite quelle
est la méthode aujourd'hui fin peut
difficilement la contester et vous
l'avez très bien expliqué heureusement
on dit maintenant je viens discuter et
ben préalable
je veux que le calme ne soit rétabli le
calme soit rétabli on l'a fait dans
d'autres circonstances on le fait ici
aujourd'hui 2,2 après les négociations
qui sont faites avec les responsables
politiques économiques etc les élus
entendus il y aura des propositions ces
propositions devront aboutir
effectivement à une réforme cette
réforme elle sera soumise s'il ya besoin
à une réforme constitutionnelle qui
veulent des trois cinquièmes ça va
prendre plusieurs mois mais
dida qui l'annoncent imaginer
aujourd'hui à cambon a accueilli quand
même situation une situation qui est
explosive si le président ne faisait
rien et qui se compte en secondes mais
qui se contenter d'envoyer des forces de
l'ordre pour rétablir l'inde pour dire
eh ben voilà c'est la matraque si ni la
matraque ni le pistolet sur la tempe
s'est dit voilà c'est une volonté de
dialogue savez c'est cette crise elle
est l'aboutissement d'années et d'années
avec la course et pas d'aujourd'hui
c'est comme les gilets jaunes ont voulu
croire que c'était l'aboutissement de
trois ans de mâcon le gilet jaune c'est
l'aboutissement de 30 ans 40 mans de
renoncement difficultés sociales
aujourd'hui là c'est la même chose et il
s'avère qu'elle s'abattent sur le
présent la république et qui tente d'y
répondre c'est pas lui qui a mis le feu
à notre dame c'est arrivé comme ça
j'entends très bien ce que je dis dire
que ce serait de sa faute c'est déjà
presque entendue donc la méthode je
pense la méthode du dialogue de
l'ouverture d'une discussion autour des
propositions et ça tombe dans la
campagne je dirais tant mieux et tant
mieux si les corses j'avais le mènent
eux-mêmes leurs impôts ça l'autonomie ou
c'est l'étape d'après je crois que ton
bien saisir les grossières possible dans
l'yonne les frontières ont été fixés sur
le régalien de l'état sur le régalien
sellette après la pub sur la santé la
fiscalité vous avez dit le foncier et le
logement des jeunes problème déjà il ya
deux problèmes la journée que le même
nom mais aujourd'hui la corse ne doit
pas vivre toujours de subventions et de
subsides elle doit avoir un
développement économique et là je crois
que dans le cadre du développement
économique elle peut aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de l'autonomie s'assurer et nous
ne pensons pas au chef de l'état
d'ouvrir le débat sur l'autonomie qu'une
majorité de français souhaitent
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle la co
officialité c'est à dire les les langues
et la langue corse dans les documents
administratifs
oui non la république et lefranc
l'erreur dans les documents ni
l'histoire dit que
tout ce qui a été refusé jusqu'à présent
et à raison dans certains cas devient
acceptable je ne suis personne ne vient
négocier je suis je bah ouais si ces
négociations
c'est certain la co officialité de la
langue corse c'est un sujet très lourd
le statut du résident c'est de mon point
de vue une mauvaise réponse à une bonne
question donc je lé bol le côté je passe
d'un extrême à l'autre me gêne quand
même si vous voulez c'est quand même un
tout petit peu gênant de dire oui ce qui
est régalien appartient à la nation tout
le reste est négociable non moi je pour
avoir un pouvoir fiscal en corse réel je
souhaite qu'il y à un état de droit
complet n'est ce pas vous savez nous
nous sommes quand même nous corse
conscients de nos propres limites de nos
propres faiblesses et il faut compter
avec et beaucoup de corses ne veulent
pas qu'on aille trop vite je pense qu'il
faut qu'on traite entre crises je pense
qu'on a un effet de serre il faut pas
lâcher n'importe quoi raconte termine
par la question du rapprochement parce
que là ça a bougé à la faveur d'ailleurs
de ce drame ou alors les décisions ont
été prises avant on va en parler un
instant il existe un peuple corse jean
via puisqu'au fond c'est ça aussi
l'inscription du peuple corse dans la
constitution dont il est question et
michel sénateurs mais si elle pas tout
le corps se seraient pas les conquérir
de l'accord sur penneteau victime donc
quelque part je dire la course était
conquise reste dans l'histoire et si
vous voulez skier aussi je crois qu'il
faut faire très attention il ya une
limite héroïque dans la jeunesse corse
parce qu'il ya eu les différentes
périodes historiques etc dont nous
essayons de ne pas faire monter la
jeunesse urbi qui on va en avoir pour 30
ans de la bourgogne aussi a été conquis
et sur juin oui la bombe médiatique au
kenya parce que en guinée on choisit ses
débats sur le peuple corse n'a aucun
intérêt de fond
français tous il suffit de dire que le
peuple corse fait partie du peuple
français ce qui me va bien sûr les
séparait jamais rentable en tout cas il
ya quelqu'un a écrit dix dans lequel des
forces comme celle de gens qui savent se
reconnaître qu'ils sont délimitées dans
un périmètre géographique qui est
absolument clair qui parle quand même
une langue qui se termine paris comme
moi alors voilà et je
sais que nous sommes profondément ému il
faut pas oublier qu'il ya une
acquisition monarchique qui a été un peu
dégueulasse vraiment mais qu'ensuite
quand les corps sont entrés dans la
république ils ont ils sont entrés
complètement dans la république et si la
corse a été délaissé les corses eux
mêmes sont allés dans les colonies ont
occupé des emplois partout et c'est
quand même la décolonisation la fin des
trente glorieuses qui ont provoqué une
amertume et comme l'art comme ça c'est
un pur le temps presse je voudrais par
françois patriat vous remonterez une
image est terminée ce débat par la
question du rapprochement des
prisonniers issa les familles le réclame
depuis des années et des années vous
souvenez peut-être lors de la visite des
manuels macron encore l'épousé d'yvan
colonna on va peut-être voir les images
les voilà elle s'était faufilé elle
était parvenue jusqu'au président de la
république pour lui demander justement
le transfèrement de son mari de la
prison d'al à la prison de borgo en
haute-corse à c'était évidemment avant
cette tentative d'assassinât il a fallu
ça pour quel gain de cause pour que ça y
est le premier ministre l'a annoncé
dans l'état où il est entre la vie et la
mort je pense que parce que la suite
d'une rencontre entre madame que l'année
il présidera publie que des réflexions
des négociations discussions lieu la
prison de borgo est en train d'être
terminée aujourd'hui à l'époque et je ne
peux pas les moyen vu son statut de la
garder tel qu'il était donc maintenant
la prison de borgo
parce que je crois que maintenant il
faut nous est terminée et que le stock
est que le statut se posera plus pour
personne que le problème va être réglé
ses 2 séparent les deux membres du
commando erignac
la décision c'est le premier ministre
qui le dit a été prise d'un
rapprochement et donc de la levée de ce
qu'on appelle le statut dps détenus
surveiller particulièrement surveillés
avant avant le drame parce qu'une
défaillance en prison alors d'accord la
défaillance en prison elle mérite tout
de même des sanctions en or et toi ya
trois ans
déjà eu des démissions on aurait demandé
des comptes d état assassin pour sept
défaillances étaient dans les
manifestations il ya une défaillance
terrible il faut tu le vis de la
condamnation alors j'étais à la
condamnation de la justice sept minutes
sur yvan colonna c'était d'être
emprisonnés c'était pas d'être
susceptible de traces un cyber nation
justement aujourd'hui le directeur
d'administration pénitentiaire a été
auditionné ya trois enquêtes et une
enquête parlementaire une enquête
administrative une enquête du
gouvernement à l'assemblée auditions de
laurent ridel il a dû justement tenté
une explication sur ces fameuses longues
minutes 9 minutes au cours desquelles
cet homme s'est jeté sur yvan colonna
écouter le fait que quelques minutes qui
peuvent être et je suis d'accord avec
vous extrêmement gravissime en soi n'est
pas et j'ai dirigé mois des
établissements notamment de maisons
centrales sa mort et poissy
je ne peux pas vous garantir
sinon je vous mentirais qu'il y à une
surveillance constante en permanence de
tous les détenus jean viard bien sûr la
justice va faire son travail parce qu il
expliqué c'est qu'il y avait un mur de
caméras cinquantaine de caméras qu'on ne
peut pas regarder tout en même temps et
ça s'est passé loin de son d'un regard
derrière derrière les gens peuvent se
comprendre mais s'ils voulaient
n'empêche que l'acte symbolique a eu
lieu à la cnps symbolique physique et
lieu donc il a besoin d'une réponse
symbolique c'est normal je leur apprends
sedan 5e temps c'est la règle on risque
fort en fait d'aboutir et si vous voulez
et qui est une faute voilà je dis pas
que c'est la faute de quelqu'un mais
derrière il faut une réponse je crois
que c'est important parce qu'on ne peut
pas laisser derrière ça l'idée d'être
encore une fois les corps sont
maltraités peut-être qu'ils en rajoutent
un peu mais n'empêche que là il a fait
tellement grave effectivement il faut en
profiter vous serez tout cas quand on va
s'arrêter la merci des débats s'achèvent
vous êtes passionné par le sujet on vous
avouerez invitera quelque chose me dit
voilà on reparle et merci à vous jean
guy talamoni d'avoir patienté à distance
merci pour vos mots vos réactions
affaire à suivre donc on sent le
gouvernement plutôt décidé mais en même
temps assez assez prudent merci à vous
pour rester avec moi j'en viens on va
parler à présent de votre livre la
france telle que je la connais votre
livre est aussi de nos territoires en
pleine mutation après le le covin
néoruraux télétravail puis la guerre en
ukraine qui nous oblige à beaucoup plus
d'indépendance énergétique mais aussi
alimentaire est ce que on est prêt à
faire des sacrifices
en tout cas on est prêt il va falloir
les faire à faire des choix on a plein
de questions à vous poser ce soir
janvier comme les ch'ti ce sujet signé
pareille d'amont à gala
si on vous invite jean viard c'est parce
que selon vous chaque crise est
créatrice avec la guerre en ukraine les
candidats s'interroge doit-on changer
nos modes de vie si pour sauver la
démocratie en europe il faut faire
tourner sa machine à laver la nuit
plutôt qu'à 18h je trouve que c'est
peut-être le prix que nous devons être
prêts à assumer l'énergie n'est pas un
luxe ni un gaspillage mais un bien de
première nécessité
jean viard vous êtes sociologue
chercheur au cevipof éditeurs dans vos
livres vous sondez l'humeur des français
pour vous déjà la pandémie a été pour
certains l'heure des choix on estime que
10 % des français sont en train de
changer de vie en chine on a le même
taux sur one à 10% des coûts par
exploser charlie 10 à plus de charges et
de conjoint changer de quartier changer
de métier et ses dires se dire quel est
le sens de ma vie au fond ce qu'on fait
tous intimement quand on a une grosse
maladie on au risque de mourir on meurt
pas et on se dit bon qu'est ce que je
fais mais choisir pas toujours facile
entre paradoxe et injonctions
contradictoires par exemple ville ou
campagne changer d'ère oui mais en
gardant les transports internet les
commerces et les écoles une campagne
version 2022 autre questionnement locale
ou internationale
manger bio produire local mais dans un
monde globalisé où la guerre en ukraine
peut entraîner une hausse des prix du
blé et déclenché une famine en afrique
petitpas ou révolution trier ses déchets
baisser le chauffage des petits gestes
du quotidien
mais est ce bien suffisant face aux
usines ou à la chine enfin jean viard
optimiste ou pessimiste
chaque crise pousse à se réinventer sauf
qu'à chaque fois on nous promet le monde
d'après et il ressemble furieusement au
monde d'avant voilà pour les questions d
amont d'un gars va ce soir c'est vrai
qu'on retrouve seul et ce fil directeur
qu'au fond toutes les crises sont source
de rebond sont source de sursaut mais là
ça fait beaucoup quand même deux fronts
pandémie climatique et maintenant
militaire avec avec la guerre ça fait
beaucoup parce qu en europe puis 50 11
70 ans pensait que les pandémies c'était
pas pour nous il est guère ce n'est pas
pour nous donc en gros moi je fais
partie de cette génération group is
enough quoi effectivement dans la guerre
au vietnam non service militaire même
aux livres etc je schématise a plu je
caricature mais c'est toute une époque
qui est une époque heureuse enfin faut
pas non plus dire le contraire qui est
en train de s'achever sens willy
chanceuse mais en même temps c'est une à
la fin et c'est aussi quelque chose de
moins contraignante que c'est peut-être
ça manquait d'exigence long pour
discuter sentant toute façon c'est fini
jeudi à la pandémie et les lieux c'est
la première fois dans l'histoire humaine
que 5 milliards d'hommes ont arrêté leur
vie pour sauver qui les improductifs les
gros les vieux les malades il faut être
fier c'est magnifique et en même temps
c'est un humanisme extraordinaire on a
sauvé entre deux et trois cents millions
de personnes on en a perdu 10 à 20
millions mais ce qu'on a le nombre de
gens qu'on a sauvés c'est des études
prospectives moi pas décompté puisqu'ils
sont pas nés moi même temps ce qu'elle
très intéressant c'est que c'est cruel
sont liées les unes aux autres son lit
la bande et mignot en gros on a
découvert la décroissance on sait tous
confinés mènerait pas prêt à relancer
modifier nos comportements culturels et
refaire confiance à la science parce
qu'elle en artois même 276 laboratoires
qui ont pour un vaccin en moins d'un an
donc c'est sa science d'un côté
modifications culturelles des
comportements et tous ensemble on peut
s'engueuler on peut être communiste on
peut être anti communistes ou n'empêche
que j'emploie climatique on travaille
plus sensation justement sur ces
injonctions contradictoires on travaille
tous ensemble vraiment sur le
réchauffement parce que regarder la
dépendance énergétique face au gaz et au
pétrole russe nous sautent au visage
mais on se rend bien compte que certains
vont aller vers le charbon
d'autres vont être aller encore plus
vers le gaz de schiste on parle aussi
d'une souveraineté alimentaire qui va
devoir construire fallait va devoir l'a
construit on voit bien qu au fond
d'urgence d'aujourd'hui avec cette
guerre
va peut-être nous faire nous asseoir sur
l'urgence climatique sion cette guerre
est absolument épouvantable d'autant
plus qu'on ne peut rien faire on peut
aider les gens qui sont besoin on peut
leur donner des armes ont plongé de
l'argent plus et délégués des trois
millions de personnes qui sont parties
dans mais c'est horrible de voir une
guerre on voit des villes démoli et c
est en gros on est chez nous on peut
rien faire parce que le monde nucléaire
est un monde où les frontières nucléaire
n'interviennent pas donc il faut dire
'ça y compris ce sentiment un peu de
honte qu'on a c'est ça le munichois
quelque part on dit oui n'aurait munich
est tout à fait mais c'est pas pareil à
l'époque on n'avait pas le nucléaire
donc ça nous blesse profondément bien
sûr plus encore les ukrainiens donc tout
cela s'il en train de bouger je dis pas
que c'est positif attendait faut pas
être fou quand même c'est une guerre
dramatique c'est à dire c'est le monde
russes quittent qui semblait se
stabiliser après l'effondrement du
communisme est à nouveau et se
déstabilise justement vous avez vu ces
appels pour des prendre un peu de la
dépendance aux hydrocarbures a baissé le
le chauffage
payer plus cher des biens alimentaires
le prix de la baguette va augmenter est
ce qu'on pensait que c'est supportable
sinon les justement d'une forme de
solidarité avec la dram aller vers une
augmentation du prix de 2 d'énergie etc
parce qu'il faut qu'on y aille le
problème c'est comment dire de manière
égale pour que les plus défavorisés
soient pas défavoriser là quelque part
ça accélère brutalement ce mouvement
mais ne rêvons pas on va pas dire que
c'est très bien oui non peut plus rouler
en voiture près blue chauffer mettez des
pull-overs attention je veux dire donc
effectivement ça va entraîner des
conséquences y en a qui vont rallumer un
peu de centrales au charbon etc là on
est une logique de guerre comme en ont
fait céder la russie c'est une logique
d'urgence dans les semaines les jours
effectivement ça c'est dur juste de
guerre
il existe le chemin mais bien sûr qu'il
existe des abords on est déjà engagé
dans ce changement les voitures ont
changé il ya des voitures électriques
partout etc je veux dire qu'il faut
faire a toujours le changement il est
déjà là ce qu'on sait pas toujours faire
c'est l'égalité faut faire attention à
la souveraineté parce que prenait la
souveraineté alimentaire c'était le
grand discours de de gaulle il avait
raison la france est indépendante avec
le nucléaire l alimentation puisque
avant on se nourrissait sur les colonies
mais l'afrique elle peut pas se nourrir
le maghreb le blé ylisma la poussée dont
clément a dit chaque âge et onéreuse
interrogé à ce propos jean viard mission
nourricière de la france ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas entendu ces
mots là je suis toujours d'accord là
dessus je veux dire ayant plus ni sur
nos réserves vis-à-vis du sud je veux
dire que on a aussi vis-à-vis du maghreb
vis-à-vis de la regarde pallier la
pénurie entraîne des semaines aliments
le liban et produisent rien donc si on
leur donne pas de bilan rien à manger
donc c'est ça aussi ça fait partie des
missions des pays que donc de l'europe
mais produire plus haut risque s'asseoir
à nouveau sur nos engagements devant la
planète on suspend ou est ce qui
effectivement on revient dessus oui il
est possible que pendant un ou deux ans
mais on ne fasse pas de jachère est-ce
que c'est complètement dramatique c'est
pas sur le problème s'ils voulaient
c'est que le monde agricole ne s'est pas
complètement adapté assez vite aux
mutations et en même temps les gens des
villes je dirais ils ont une vision bobo
est un peu bohème bobo de l'agriculture
et des problèmes écolo mais ils ont pris
font pression pour l'écologie donc c'est
très bien mais le monde agricole se
transforme mais peut-être pas assez vite
donc si vous voulez là dessus ne montons
pas toujours des infos mais il faut
faire une parenthèse parce qu'ils ont
besoin de manger cette année pire la
victoire ils ont besoin de manger tout
de suite donc je veux dire
avec la chine elle a un an d'avancé de
réserves de blé dont ils font des
réserves nous en a vingt jours donc si
vous voulez là ils font fait il faut
être là il ya une urgence oui cette
année il faut la brûler cette année il
faut donner une autorisation pour un non
oui vous avez une réflexion très
intéressante d'ailleurs sur la question
des réfugiés votre livre a été écrit
avant la guerre en ukraine cent mille
réfugiés vont arriver jusqu'à 100000 en
france parler d'un humanisme et d'une
fraternité heureuse un petit mot pour
terminer sur cette france telle que vous
la connaissez pour reprendre le titre de
votre livre quelle est elle après après
enquête m'initier vous savez s'il ya une
chose dont on est juste un chiffre que
j'adore il faut avant la pandémie 75%
des gens disaient qu'ils étaient heureux
maintenant on est 80 % dont on ne sait
des gens heureux dans une france en
crise et ça le problème c'est que au
fond les gens sont vous promener partout
dans la vie privée dans la vie amicale
etc les gens sont plutôt il ya des gens
très malheureux il ya des gens pauvres
dire ça se superposent pas toujours mais
après c'est plutôt un pays qui tourne
bien faut faire très attention après on
le monde comme étant un feu à sang il ya
des conflits à des tensions et les
gilets jaunes comme ça je suis tout à
fait consentie
c'est un pays profondément terriens en
ce moment les gens ont tendance à se
rapprocher les petites villes ayem
mouvement vers les campagnes il ya 70%
des français qui ont un jardin
je veux dire c'est un pays de deux
maisons avec jardin on a une vision
dirait qu'on aboutisse dans des tours
c'est bien moi j'adore la villa mais je
veux dire on mais on reste un grand pays
agricole terriens et c'est crois qu'il
faut se dire c'est pourtant excusez moi
ce tapis a pu voir magnifique essai le
rares pays au monde qui est touristique
partout donc on a restauré jusqu'au
dernier de l'avoir eh ben ça c'est
plutôt de bons petits
mousses et du bien vous rester avec moi
allez on ouvre la page présidentielle à
25 jours à présent du premier tour ça
s'appelle le scan vous connaissez
désormais
mervans les dons il y avait deux pas de
fatalité au grand remplacement et bien
molle vous propose le rose dalmore
d'agir pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la france orange
ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs le système
bose exclu il ya un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la france sa
grandeur caritas a pas de mystère c'est
le vol
bonsoir à vous chers scanner on vous
appelle comme ça désormais en tout le
monde serre chroniqueur véronique rice
ould black bones consulting ces sages
bakbone pardonnez moi pour parler des
réseaux sociaux va parler des
influenceurs leur rôle dans la campagne
fanny guinochet france info radio
l'économie mais très importante
aujourd'hui beaucoup d' annonce sur le
pouvoir d'achat et on va commencer avec
le carnet de campagne de stéphane
stéphane blakowski qu'est ce qui a
attiré votre oeil aujourd'hui et ben
figurez vous et mariam que depuis ce
matin il ya un petit truc qui me
chiffonne alors rien de grave vous allez
voir c'est vraiment bénin malgré tout
j'ai découvert en lisant le parisien que
tous les sondages qui nous annonce que
macro est arrivé en tête au premier tour
sont probablement faux pardon oh oui son
fois mon avis sont faux est ce qui vous
arrive d'être devenu complotistes alors
dans ces pages pas du tout c'est moins
grave enfin que cinq au maximum de la
même promo reproché de jouer sur les
mots mais excusez moi si oui tout à fait
possible que au soir du premier tour le
nombre de français qui ont voté pour
malema qu'on soit inférieur au nombre de
français qui n'ont pas été voter donc
que va dire l'opinion que va dire la
presse que le vrai vainqueur du premier
tour elle allait pas macron c'est
l'abstention donc le président sera
évidemment affaiblie alors avant même
d'avoir été réélu à quel niveau
risque-t-il d'être ce 7 abstentions il
ya beaucoup de craintes à tubes a
remarqué aussi à quel niveau mais on
observe le sondage tous les jours on les
regarde au 2000 points près dans ce
mouchoir de poche mais qui est devant
zemmour pécresse mélenchon on ne sait
pas en revanche personnes sont sous
plateau n'est capable de mener les
estimations pour la fonction au 1er tour
c'est pour ça vous vous dites 30% je la
regarde et on va ré demander où sont
leurs aux instituts de sondages ils se
sont penchés sur la question regarder
alors quand on demande à gaël sliman de
doxa lui dit on a fait les intrus d'hp à
plus de 25% l'abstention donc on peut
demander à revenge larbi de brice
teinturier qui buta ipsos lors nous dit
attention d'un an dont on va battre des
records on va certainement être au
dessus des 28 qui était d'accord jusqu'à
présent on va monter jusqu'à 31 ou 35 2%
l'abstention donc la fourchette c'est
l'abstention c'est entre 25 et 35% c'est
l'un des critères les plus essentielles
pourraient comprendre cette élection en
est incapable
de mesurer tout cas elle est donnée à la
hausse 1 pour cette élection là c'est
très clair comment la faire baisser
cette attaque alors je pense que si on
avait deux solutions on leur a déjà mis
en place tout ça dure quand même depuis
les années 70 est donc montée de
l'abstention mais dans l'immédiat tous
les un contre les adversaires de macro
ont une idée en plus ça tombe bien c'est
la même c il faut absolument que le
président vienne débattre pour relancer
l'intérêt des électeurs sur ce quota on
écoute j'arrache et qui s'est exprimé m
sur le président du sénat survient après
les discussions cette grande
conversation démocratique qui doit être
la nôtre est indispensable dans une
allocution les risques les riches ces
quelques mois après qu'ils aient des
crises de légitimité
alors le pire que même si gérard larcher
président du sénat ne devrait peut-être
pas dire ça le pire ce qu'il a peut-être
raison vraisemblablement on se souvient
que déjà qu'en 2017 l'élection de macron
avait été contesté en l'occurrence par
mélenchon dec deuxième tour en disant
notamment sur l'argument de la situation
au second tour qui avait été record en
2017 ce procès est élégant léger des
jaunes ont contesté la légitimité du
président macron donc forcément si en
2022 il est réélu mais que à nouveau
l'abstention bat à taux record qu'est ce
qu'il est ce que de se passer on écoute
les prévisions de valérie pécresse
s'il ya une abstention massive parce que
il n'y a pas de débat démocratique parce
que les français qui sont en colère se
disent que finalement à aucun moment ils
n'ont eu la possibilité de débattre face
à face avec le président est de
confronter leurs souffrances leurs
difficultés du quotidien les difficultés
nos services publics de l'hôpital alors
réaliser la justice alors à l'élection
sera illégitime non alors il y aura une
colère et une frustration
on pensait qu'il va finir par l'accepter
au fond ce débat pour les c'est
justement à prendre le risque moi je
vois pas trop personnes honnêtes
services français marine le pen elle non
plus ne veut pas débattre avec les moins
bien classées qu'elles veux bien
débattre avec castex éventuellement mais
pas avec les autres dont on attend que
la campagne peut-être redémarre puisque
l'abstention est toujours là si demain
macro nous fait un grand show et que les
journalistes lui posent des questions
qui vont relancer la campagne
certainement mais sinon qui est
évidemment candidat ou plutôt le
candidat
va dévoiler son programme présidentiel
demain on en parlera évidemment demain
soir jean viard ce risque d'illégitimité
d'une campagne extrêmement courte pour
la république n'a jamais des matières
dans le premier tour gd faut faire
attention à ce qu'on raconte évidemment
un argument ça et puis bien entendu si
vous mettez 12 personnes face à un
candidat il est sortant le monde de lui
taper dessus c'est pas un débat je veux
dire donc c'est pour ça qu'ils ne l'ont
jamais fait
si vous voulez donc mais non parce que
vous mettez les douze personnes en face
du président macron ils vont lui tirer
dessus ou pour montrer lequel est le
plus méchant en disant ça me fait
récupérer des voix ça sera pas non plus
intéressant je voudrais juste dire une
chose savaient l'élection est elle plus
de votants c'est l'affrontement sarkozy
ségolène royal pourquoi parce que
c'était un magnifique spectacle faut pas
oublier que la politique c'est moitié
spectacles à venir moitié contenu quand
il ya pas de spectacle il ya place en
temps ça qu'on demande un débat c'est
parce que ça fait un grand
alors fait on va parler d'une annonce
importante aujourd'hui celle du premier
ministre qui vient de présenter son plan
de résilience pour aider les français à
faire face à l'inflation oui alors jean
castex a surtout dévoilé toute une série
de mesures pour les entreprises les
agriculteurs les pêcheurs les
transporteurs parce qu'il ne veut pas
casser la croissance et c'est vrai que
ces entreprises prennent de plein fouet
la hausse des matières premières la
hausse de l'énergie notamment à cause de
la guerre en ukraine en fait ils
réactivent des mesures du quoi qu'il en
coûte beaucoup pour soutenir les ménages
il avait déjà fait 'l'annonce dès ce
week end une réduction de 15 centimes
par litre de carburant à partir du 1er
avril
ça sert d'amortisseur et c'est vrai que
ça vient en plus du bouclier tarifaires
et ça n'est pas neutre un parce que par
exemple ce bouclier tarifaire l'insee a
calculé laisser tomber la cet après midi
que se bouclait tarifaire avait permis
de baisser d'un point et demi
l'inflation on aurait eu en arriverait à
se répéter à 3,6 pour cent ont sans
l'aide de l'état on serait à 5 à plus de
5% donc c'est vrai que ça n'est pas
neutre cet ensemble de mesures que le
gouvernement déploie alors ça n'est pas
neutre non plus sur les déficits
effectivement à ça n'est pas gratuit
rien que si on prend le total entre la
prime inflation le bouclier tarifaire on
en a bruno le maire le président précisé
cet après midi jusqu'à 24
25 milliards d'euros dont voyez c'est
pas une petite facture c'est l'ensemble
des mesures que déploie le gouvernement
pour essayer de freiner la hausse des
carburants des prix de l'alimentaire
alors après tout la question c'est
évidemment entre ce que l'on ressent et
puis ce qui est fait réellement alors
tous les opposants emmanuel macron dans
cette campagne explique qu ils crament
la caisse c'est pécresse en tout cas qui
qui sort le carnet de chèques c'est
nouveau ça finalement qu'un président à
toute fin de son mandat fassent des
annonces aussi coûteuse n'ont cessé ces
deux traditions mais c'est vrai que là
on est dans un class particulier il ya
eu le coc vide maintenant il ya la
guerre en ukraine qui sera pas neutre 1
sur les finances publiques et qui sera
pas neutre sur notre économie l'insee à
d'ailleurs dit que ça allait freiner la
croissance alors en même temps c'est
vrai qu'on peut se dire que c'est une
drôle de coïncidence que d'annoncer le
dégel du point d'indicé pour six
millions de fonctionnaires
deux jours avant une grève qui
d'ailleurs sera suivie à une grève
demain des services publics ne sera
d'ailleurs décidé que si mm après lui
puisqu'il faudra une loi et ça c'est
après nestlé après alors c'est donc une
promesse douala il sait plus trop bien
l'indicé on semblait foncer février-mars
sais pas de combien aussi attention bien
que ça va des ponts mais c'est vrai que
dans un contexte avec une inflation qui
est donnée à 4% cette année c'est grosso
modo les prévisions de la banque de
france ou même de l'insee on se dit que
c'est difficile pour un gouvernement de
ne rien faire sans aide les ménages les
plus pauvres serait étranglé les
entreprises on le voit à certaines ont
déjà arrêté de produire et 10 bat on
préfère ne rien faire plutôt que de
travailler à perte et puis ça occasionne
des tensions sociales on commence à le
voir en bretagne il y a des raffineries
qui sont bloqués ça occasionne de la
colère et ça évidemment quelques
semaines avant une élection un
gouvernement ne veut pas se le permettre
bon je ne vais pas réagir là-dessus
j'imagine que voilà vous comprenez que
il faut aller jusqu'au bout ou gouvernés
jusqu'au bout surtout dans l'abonnement
les choses sont tellement entre le monde
bouge et dans tous les bouts il aurait
rien faire aurait dit font rien ils font
ça on dit fort de l'électoralisme en
disposent parce que vous aimez jouer si
sap les idéateurs leurs fins de mois
c'est pas mal jean viard les
influenceurs des dunes est un peu un peu
moisie arrêté avec véronique c'est aussi
de comprendre sont des nouveaux acteurs
de la com paul comme on dit la
communication politique ils sont très
présents dans dans la campagne qui sont
ils ces influenceurs verdict exactement
alors il y en a je vous en prendre trois
peut-être cela réponse l'abstentéisme ce
que c'est une façon d'intéresser des
jeunes publics il ya à prendre une
influence us qui s'appelle magali
bernard berda pardon un animateur que
vous connaissez qui essayait d'hanouna
mais qu'on peut ranger dans la catégorie
des influences et puis un journaliste
s'appelle hugo travers qui lui aussi est
un d'influenceurs même s'il est un
journaliste hugo décrypte c'est ça voilà
alors ce sont eux qui créent l'événement
dans cette campagne pourquoi alors
écrire l'événement parce que finalement
ils ont des nouveaux formats une
nouvelle façon de travailler une
nouvelle façon d'interpeller si on prend
par exemple madame berda c'est une
influence euse c'est une femme
d'affaires à diriger une société qui est
plutôt prospère elle gère des stars de
la télé réalité et elle a appliqué la
même chose pour les candidats donc cette
passion oui alors oui francis qu on vous
suit parfaitement à l'antenne puisqu'on
n'a pas de retour ici dans les écrans
mais on voit on voit dame bernadette et
madame berda pour vous donner une idée à
la minute où le voir sur instagram et
elle fait une émission qui dure 35
minutes en immersion à chaque fois avec
des candidats elle pose des questions un
peu incongru ou les uns et les autres
répondent c'est très suivie et vous avez
des protagonistes de la télé-réalité
l'impression vous subissez comment on
appelle ça le bellevue matching voilà ça
d'être pesant quand même
les codes de la téléréalité pour
favoriser
des questions que les gens se posent en
tout cas et c'est une autre façon de
faire de la com paul
on n'influence certes mais est ce que ça
bouge les lignes électorale vraiment c
est flatteur ces nouveaux acteurs cela
peut potentiellement bouger les lignes
électorale on va revenir sur le cas de
monsieur hanouna oui monsieur hanouna
keane star incontournable de singly on
peut l'appeler le ba-ba parce que
c'était donc son papa lui donner je
crois il a 6 millions de followers sur
twitter et là un million de followers
sur instagram et la 1,9 million il
falloir sur facebook et surtout il a une
communauté assez incroyable c'est le
seul à avoir ça beaucoup de médias
aimerait avoir offert aux les fans 12 et
des fantous pour vous donner une idée
c'est
2282 compte twitter qui reprennent tout
et qui sont eux mêmes très suivie ces
142 chaîne youtube donc en fait il là
une communauté qui reprend tout ce qu'il
dit tout ce qu'il fait et du coup permet
d'ailleurs d'adapter un tous ses
programmes du coup il se permet de
casser des codes et de faire des choses
que beaucoup de journalistes en a
peut-être aimé et effectivement ça fait
voter en tout cas ça intéresse et les
fameux phase où sont censés être des
gens qui ne votent pas aujourd'hui donc
explique voter grâce à ses émissions
cela on va voir au travers où on
s'arrête quelques instants parce que
c'est plus particulier c'est un
journaliste un journaliste qui à 24 ans
qui à la tête d'une entreprise lui aussi
plutôt fructueuse il a une chaîne avec
1,5 million d'abonnés une chaîne youtube
instagram à 6 millions d'abonnés
tik tok 1,9 million d'abonnés il aussi
sur tweets sur twitter
et juste pour vous donner une idée en
fait c'est quelqu'un qui parle aux
jeunes très jeunes qui sont souvent ceux
qui ne votent pas il a une façon de les
interpeller avesnois des trois actuels
en dix minutes exactement c'est une
façon et
ça fonctionne très bien et là bas et
s'est invitée dans la campagne
évidemment avec l'interview face cachée
c'est un petit format de 30 40 minutes
où les candidats sont face à un écran
alors beaucoup rails mais c'est très
efficace et qui sont prises dans cl vous
laisse écouter ça se fait dans un cadre
très particulier chaque candidat fait
face un écran géant sur lequel défilent
une mouvement des mauges y à plusieurs
reprises en appuyant sur le buzzer
l'arrêtent voilà donc c'est pour vous
dire vu comme ça ça fait plutôt sourire
on va dire que même les spécialistes de
la communication politique qui sont des
gens très sérieux
sourire en disant que les ignorants
informe les ignorants on va pas très
loin mais la réalité c'est que ça
fonctionne ça fait dire des choses
différentes c'est une façon de il plus
efficace alors bal de la rose et les
quelques secondes la plus efficace on va
dire que c'est celui qui utilise le
réseau qui montent le plus ce ton que
hugo décrypte avec tik tok mais pour
parler à ceux qui sont à la frontière de
s'intéresser à l'éthique c'est baba bon
bah qui est d'ailleurs sa marine le pen
sait pas aller voter bon bah voilà vous
contestez bien ce soir et si c'était un
moyen pas si c'était un moyen de les
mobiliser allez voter quelque chose
merci à vous merci jean viard je
rappelle le titre de votre livre la
france telle que je la connais on peut
picorer de courts chapitres ses traits
voilà c'est très vivifiant pour la
réfection et puis c'est toujours très
optimiste on en a besoin en cette
période difficile merci à vous très
belle soirée à demain
[Musique]